A woman walks through the lonely hills in
the dead of night.
Her purple sari is torn and filthy from days
of exposure to the elements; her bare feet
have been cut up and bruised by the rough
terrain she walks.
But her clothes and her feet are not the most
noticeable thing about her: This woman is
pregnant, her belly swollen
to freakish proportions.
It’s frankly a miracle that she’s even
able to walk in this state.
She stumbles and sways under the weight of
the thing growing inside her.
Whatever it is, it’s too large to be any
kind of ordinary baby.
But she keeps moving, muttering to herself
in a language that no human ear has heard
in years.
Her eyes are glazed over, almost hypnotized.
She moves with great purpose, but her vacant
facial expression makes it appear as though
she doesn’t know exactly what that purpose
is.
She just needs to keep moving further into
the wilderness until “It” happens, whatever
“It” is.
The one thing that’s certain is that It
isn’t anything good.
A car rumbles down a nearby dirt road.
It’s being driven by Dr. Vinay Ramachandran,
a medical practitioner from the nearby city
of Surat who occasionally drives out to more
rural areas, where the locals might not have
easy access to medical help.
He spots the staggering woman and immediately
pumps the breaks of his car.
She’s clearly in need of medical attention,
thank goodness he happened to be driving by
at the time!
Dr. Ramachandran grabs his medical bag from
the back seat and rushes towards the woman,
who collapses in a heap before he reaches
her.
That’s when, to his utter horror, Dr. Ramachandran
notices that the woman’s belly is continuing
to swell at an unnatural rate.
Even for a woman who was heavily pregnant
with triplets, this would still be far too
large.
And the rate at which she’s swelling is
akin to someone blowing up a balloon.
By the time Dr. Ramachandran reaches her,
the worst has already happened.
The woman’s belly has burst open, and crouching
on her corpse is the thing that was growing
inside her: An adult man, nude and covered
in blood.
Dr. Ramachandran’s terror only increases
when he notices that the man is eating her.
Elsewhere, a riot is unfolding in the streets.
A megaphone-wielding instigator barks orders
for violence and chaos as the rioters spread,
setting fires, smashing windows, and attacking
any unfortunate civilians caught in their
way.
It’s one of the worst riots that the area
has ever seen.
Even the veteran riot cops are frightened
by the ferocity of it.
The cops descend and clash with the crowd
of ever-advancing rioters.
They’re beaten back with crowbars, baseball
bats, knives, and metal pipes.
And behind them all, the instigator continues
spitting his venomous words, working the crowd
into an unmatchable frenzy.
They’ll need heavy reinforcements if they
want to get this riot under control.
That’s when one of the riot cops on the
front line, Sergeant Abhishek, notices something
strange: So many of the rioters seem to have
the exact same face.
The face of the instigator.
Another place, another time, four men are
digging up a grave in a desolate old graveyard.
They work tirelessly, all moving in perfect
synchronicity.
They’re only interrupted when a group of
heavily-armed men crash the party and start
firing on them.
But these graverobbers are prepared.
All of them draw revolvers like a gang in
an old Western and begin returning fire, causing
the men in tactical gear to seek cover behind
the nearby tombstones.
While one of the graverobbers continues to
fire, the other three
scatter during the confusion.
When his gun runs dry with that telltale click,
the men in tactical gear immediately rise
up and pincushion him with shot after shot
of their assault rifles.
He does the bullet dance like Tony Montana
and collapses to the ground.
But when the gunmen approach to confirm the
kill, there’s a horrifying twist of fate:
Swarms of horrible red flies start pouring
out of every bullet wound, swarming the attackers,
who retreat, swatting away these horrible
little insects.
But there’s so many of them.
There’s no way to stop at least some of
them from crawling into their mouths.
Here’s an interesting fact: All of these
nightmarish incidences are connected.
In the year 1969, a mysterious man was arrested
in Himatnagar, an area in the Indian state
of Gujarat.
This man had been accused of inciting civil
unrest, terrorizing and distressing the local
people.
He was later extradited to an unknown location
after the Indian authorities received a request
from a mysterious organization known as - yep,
you guessed it - the SCP Foundation.
Who could this man have possibly been to attract
such attention?
The authorities thought it best not to question
it, they were probably just glad to be rid
of the troublemaker once and for all.
Except they weren’t - Not by a long shot.
A few years later, in 1975, a group of four
men were discovered in a cemetery, this time
in Ahmedabad, another location in Gujarat,
India, for desecrating graves.
This would be strange and upsetting enough,
but what really sent things to the next level
of weirdness was the discovery that these
four men were all the same man.
each one was not only genetically identical
to one another, but also to the man that had
been extradited in 1969.
You’d be more than justified in asking,
“What the hell is going on here?
Maybe they were a group of
highly rare quintuplets,
five children all born from the same mother,
who just happened to have a predilection towards
crime and antisocial behavior.
Or perhaps something stranger was afoot: The
four who appeared in the cemetery might have
been clones of the original troublemaker in
Himatnagar.
As relatively simple as those explanations
would be, the truth was in fact far, far weirder
than mad science or coincidentally criminal
quintuplets.
The four from the cemetery had been ambushed
by operatives of the Global Occult Coalition,
another shadowy organization fans of this
channel are likely to recognize.
The Coalition, or “GOC”, is a group that
views itself as the police of the paranormal
world, using extremely advanced technology
to destroy supernatural entities and artifacts
rather than contain them.
They’ve been known to work both alongside
and against the SCP Foundation; both groups’
combined interest in four genetically identical
men in an Indian graveyard seems to suggest
there was something supernatural about their
origin.
One of the men had been killed by the GOC,
while the remaining three were taken into
custody by the SCP Foundation.
Gotta love the power of teamwork.
But who were these men?
Where had they come from and why did they
share identical genes to the first man from
six years earlier?
Could there have been even more of them?
Well, in the years following, the Foundation
has been able to determine that, yes, there
are more of these genetically
identical individuals
out there.
Across the more rural states of India, like
Gujarat, Rajasthan, Himachal Pradesh, Haryana,
Punjab, Jammu, and Kashmir, there may be over
a thousand instances of the same person.
Collectively, they are known as SCP-2833.
While their outward appearances can vary somewhat,
instances of SCP-2833 all share the exact
same genetic traits as each other.
Depending on the area they are located in,
these anomalous people can speak various languages
and regional dialects including Hindi, English,
Gujarati, Dogri, Kashmiri, Punjabi, Urdu,
and even an outdated, unknown language that
doesn’t correspond with any known modern
dialect or language family.
Each SCP-2833 also possesses the ability to
manipulate the organic matter of their own
body.
Now, we don’t mean that these men will stretch
themselves like Mr. Fantastic , or turn into
something out of John Carpenter’s The Thing
but they are able to use their bodies to create…
well, something.
SCP-2833 instances can produce a small anomalous
parasite, known as SCP-2833-A. These are often
released through any bodily orifice like the
mouth, nose, or ears, or through any cuts
or open wounds suffered by an SCP-2833.
In other words, if you shot and killed an
SCP-2388, perhaps in a cemetery under the
orders of the Global Occult Coalition, then
these parasites would still be able to escape
through the victim’s bullet wounds.
The only way to stop this from happening is
to incinerate the body of a deceased SCP-2833,
burning them until there is nothing left.
So, what exactly are these parasites?
Well, they’re tiny invertebrates, meaning
they’re a small, cold-blooded organism with
no spine that can live on land or in water.
They closely resemble Dipterans, which are
any order of insects that contain what we
know as flies.
Red in color and twenty millimeters in length,
SCP-2833-As are composed of a combination
of muscle tissue, keratin - the protein that
your hair, skin, and fingernails are made
from - and traces of ash, strangely enough.
They are also capable of flying with their
two wings and will use these to attempt to
enter the body of a suitable host.
While this can be any vertebrate creature,
it seems they have a preference for humans.
Once inside the host’s body, an SCP-2833-A
parasite will attach itself to their nervous
system.
This then allows the SCP-2833 instance that
the parasite originated from to control the
body of the host, taking over their bodily
and motor functions, nervous system, and all
of their sensory organs.
From here, an SCP-2833 will then either subject
the target to vivid, inescapable hallucinations,
or manipulate the functions of their body.
The parasites also contain a miniature instance
of another SCP-2833, only about two millimeters
long.
While these mini SCP-2833s are usually chemically
inactive, lying dormant and unable to move,
this changes if the parasite’s host is a
human female.
In these cases, the SCP-2833-A creature will
implant the miniature SCP-2833 within the
uterus of their female host.
After this, the new SCP-2833 will begin to
rapidly grow, consuming any and all organic
matter that surrounds it.
Once again, the SCP-2833 that the parasite
originated from is still able to manipulate
the female host’s body and will use this
control to make her leave her home and travel
away from any urban environment.
After a year, the new instance of SCP-2833
will be born in a truly horrific fashion.
Every time this happens, the female host is
unable to survive the process, dying as a
result of being used as an incubator for the
parasites.
The newly formed SCP-2833 will retain all
the memories of the previous instance that
released the parasite.
They are even able to speak fluently from
the moment they are born.
But that isn’t the most horrific part.
What happens next is that the newborn SCP-2833
will then devour the body of the female host
that carried it.
Sometimes, the host can die before an SCP-2833
is born, with the parasite keeping their body
embalmed until the new instance emerges.
But regardless, the “mother” of an SCP-2833
will always die during birth.
The SCP Foundation has conducted a number
of interviews with the instances of SCP-2833
that they have captured and detained.
The first, SCP-2833-1, the man causing civil
unrest in Himatnagar, 1969, referred to himself
as ‘we’, implying that all of the SCP-2833
instances share the same consciousness, acting
as a hive mind of sorts.
One of the men from the cemetery, SCP-2833-4,
elaborated further on the nature of these
anomalous beings when asked how many other
instances existed:
“We are in your cages.
We are distant from the hordes of the ignorant.
We are grown like crops and livestock.
We are growing in numbers and faith, and we
will grow until the ascension of Samādhi…
Samādhi is beyond sight… the buried will
rise.
To be consumed is the doorway to rebirth.
This is our cycle, waiting for Samādhi with
patience.
We shall dance the Tandava and consume the
world for its rebirth.”
“Samādhi” is a word meaning a crypt,
usually the final resting place of a saint
or someone of religious significance.
Additionally, the “Tandava” is an ancient
dance, that according to legends, was performed
by the Hindu god Shiva
, who was believed to be the source of all
things, the cycle of creation, preservation,
and destruction.
So, these anomalous beings and their parasites
appeared to be awaiting the discovery of an
ancient burial site, where someone or something
was prophesied to rise, consume the world,
and then recreate it.
Thinking this Samādhi might pose a threat,
the Foundation probed a later instance of
SCP-2833 for further
information on its significance.
“If you intend to seek Samādhi, your quest
is in vain.
For we are the inheritor to Samādhi.
Only we!”
SCP-2833-42 protested when asked about the
Samādhi by a Foundation researcher, one Doctor
Sanjay Sheel.
“Samādhi does not threaten.
It is we who were threatened, exiled when
the Colossi overran Samādhi.
We are the remnants, but we are never defeated.”
The instance went on.
“We are of glorious lineage, the chosen
stock of Karcist Vaski.
Only the strongest and most zealous may serve
his purpose.
To that end, we cut and consume ourselves
to persist and await for Samādhi.”
When asked who exactly Karcist Vaski was,
SCP-2833-42 answered “We are.
We are Karcist Vaski.”
That word, “Karcist”, has long been associated
with the religious cult of Sarkicism, another
group of interest you’re likely to be familiar
with if you’re a fan of what we do here.
This group worships flesh and disease and
is seen as an apocalyptic threat by the SCP
Foundation.
The Sarkicist religion was founded thousands
of years ago by an ancient elder being known
as the Sorcerer-King of Adytum, also called
Grand Karcist Ion.
The goal of Sarkicism is to bring about a
new age of flesh, elevating humanity to the
form of gods and potentially terraforming
the entire Earth using SCP-610, The Flesh
that Hates.
So, who or what was Karcist Vaski?
What role did it have in the religion of Sarkicism
and how does it link to SCP-2833?
The Foundation has collected a number of documents
once belonging to a man named Sir William
Henry Sleeman.
Sleeman was an administrator who worked in
India on behalf of the British East India
Company before his death in 1856.
And it is in his documents that some of the
answers can be found.
According to Sir William, the poor of India
told him about a group of mystics, who were
both revered and feared among the country’s
peasantry.
This group called themselves the Vātula,
and seemed to hold what Sleeman described
as “an unusual fetish towards death and
decay”.
Sounds an awful lot like the Sarkicists, doesn’t
it?
Sir William heard rumors that these Vātula
worshiped Shiva, but were never seen at temples,
choosing instead to worship the Hindu god
in seclusion.
Additionally, though, each member of the Vātula,
when asked, identified themselves by the title
of “Karcist Vaski.”
Not everyone feared them, however, as a group
of men would often attack them.
These men were Thuggee, organized gangs of
professional robbers and murderers that traveled
India, strangling their victims to death and
robbing them blind.
Perhaps because of this, the Vātula seemed
wary to interact with any other worshippers
of Shiva, often dismissing them as pretenders
to the faith.
Hoping to appease and gain an audience with
the Vātula, Sir William’s allies unleashed
what they called the Daughter of Shadows,
better known as SCP-029.
This divided the Thuggee, in the hopes that
the Vātula would then accept Sleeman as an
ally.
Eventually, he achieved an audience with them
and was unable to determine whether this group
was genuinely devoted to their religious beliefs
or was just a group of madmen.
What Sir William didn’t realize, was that
under the vestige of “Karcist Vaski”,
this group was subtly spreading the influence
of Sarkicism over India.
As for SCP-2833, perhaps they are the descendants
of the Vātula group, their lineage continuing
through the passing of those little parasites.
It’s highly likely that these Vātula were
all early instances of SCP-2833, which would
explain why those captured by the SCP Foundation
claim that they are all Karcist Vaski.
A few years back in 2014, one of the Foundation’s
Mobile Task Forces uncovered a body that was
a genetic match to the other instances of
SCP-2833.
However, this one wasn’t found in India,
but in Krasnoyarsk Krai, Russia.
It had strange growths on its muscle tissue
and bones, carrying multiple SCP-2833-A parasites
inside its internal organs.
The body had even been modified to contain
an artificial uterus, which carried an infant
SCP-2833 instance.
It seems that not only have SCP-2833 found
a new way to evolve, carrying themselves in
a modified body, but they’re also beginning
to spread further than ever before.
You’ve gotta hand it to the Sarkicists - They’re
certainly adaptable.
Now go check out “SCP-3989 - The Bone Orchard”
and “SCP-610 - The Flesh That Hates” for
more scary Sarkicist SCPs!